[Music]
it's supposed to be 70 degrees today at
freezing here
speaking of global warming where is we
need some global warming it's freezing
the most criticized scene in the movie
An Inconvenient Truth was showing that
the combination of sea level rise and
storm surge would flood the 9/11
memorial site and people said what a
terrible exaggeration Hurricane sandy
slammed into New York City last night
plotting the World Trade Center site
storms get stronger and more destructive
watch the water splash off the city this
is global warming I threw up scared
sweet despair can be Hara lysing but
this to me is the most exciting new
development we're seeing a tremendous
amount of positive change the basis is
there but it's still not enough it's
crunch time a DA climate change
conference in Paris there's some really
tough negotiations going on what would
it take the shift to renewables I'm
talking about breaking the impasse
virtually every nation in the entire
world agreed to get to zero greenhouse
emissions it is unprecedented it's time
to put America first that includes the
promise to cancel billions in climate
change spending our plan will end the
EPA
the next generation would be justified
in looking back at us and asking what
were you thinking couldn't you hear what
the scientists were saying couldn't you
hear what Mother Nature was screaming at
you this movement is in the tradition of
every great movement that has advanced
humankind when our going to recognize it
we don't want to discuss it
[Music]
it is right to save humanity it is wrong
to pollute this earth it is right to
give hope to the future generation
don't let anybody tell you that we're
gonna get on rocket ships and live on
Mars this is our home sorry